boa noite a todos
que satisfação estar aqui justamente
hoje para podermos refletir
nós somos essencialmente na sociedade
reflexiva
de um jeito ou de outro mesmo quando a
gente não reflete de algum modo a nossa
postura é reflexiva e pensando no poder
das palavras hoje à tarde eu escrevi
estas a força da palavra a palavra está
uma força poderosa que revoluciona
impulsiona direcionem fascina na palavra
está uma força poderosa que educa
conserva qualifica robustece e ensina
uma força imensa que ele fica
preserva purifica santifica enriquece
uma força que envolve nove comove
converte em cantar uma força que quer
branca levanta transforma e regenera a
palavra é portadora de sabedoria e
discernimento sim ou não ela é sempre
revelação a palavra alimenta a emoção a
paixão a ação a palavra fonte suplemento
que renova nossas forças nas horas
tristes nas dores do coração mas a
palavra é também arma de combate defende
e mata abre e fecha surpreende e ataca é
credencial que dá acesso impede entradas
condena o acusado o
liberta o inocente da prisão a palavra
salvo e perdoa cura em ressuscita a
palavra mata maltrata é torpedo que
defende o é bomba de destruição tudo
depende do seu uso da sua ação
a palavra levantem derruba agrada
desagrada é emociona e rita afasta traz
para perto é mel o fel exprime amor
ternura respeito admiração e num tom de
raiva exprime rancor e ódio escondidos
no coração
a palavra sendo verdade ou mentira
sempre causará o seu efeito uma ação é
com estas palavras que eu gostaria de
começar a minha história com vocês hoje
porque eu sou padre
sou professor já trabalhei no teatro
trabalho na tevê trabalho no rádio
essencialmente ministro tudo lidamos com
que com a palavra quando vamos escrever
quando vamos falar quando vamos fazer
tantas coisas é a palavra que nós usamos
mas eu agora quero me recordar daquelas
muitas pessoas que eu conheci ao longo
da vida e que me encheram o coração de
imensa em profunda alegria quando por
exemplo chegaram ao longo de suas vidas
eu já tenho 26 anos de padre puderam me
dizer assim o momento mais feliz da
minha vida eu acabei de viver e eu diria
que foi meu namorado vendesse o dia
muitos dizem assim a dengue e fiquei com
as pernas bambas
outros dizem eu fiquei tão colorada que
eu não sabia o que fazer
outros diziam eu coração disparado
eu achei que eu ia ter um próximo veja a
força que tem
uma palavra porque na verdade já
namoravam
talvez até ela já soubesse que ele amava
mas nada foi igual a aquele momento em
que a palavra foi disparada e chegou a
vida e de si mas também já houve muita
tristeza pessoas que chegam que tristes
às vezes chorando justamente dizem o
contrário quando falam padre acabou tudo
isso que ele disse que não me ama mas
acabou tudo e agora é a minha vida
construindo os meus filhos ea minha casa
e as minhas coisas ea minha vida como
fica
são as mesmas palavras
tinha sim então muitas vezes uma
palavrinha que nós utilizamos muda
completamente
as palavras maravilhosas bonitas
extraordinárias têm força mas as
palavras maldosas também tem a grande
questão é a gente saber mas será que a
palavra pela palavra tem alguma força
independente de quem fala de quem diz
independente da emoção independente da
ação será que seu encontro a palavra
qualquer aí jogada no chão escutada ao
vento será que isso tem alguma força
para mim experimento encontrá las
e você verá como a palavra por si só ela
tem força suficiente para alterar o seu
comportamento e muitas vezes o seu
estado emocional
mas a palavra
não é só falada ou escrita
há também muitas outras palavras
inclusive a palavra não dita
talvez nada pior do que alguém chega
para você dizer assim
então você ainda me ama e não tem
resposta
talvez esta seja pior de todas as
palavras que não foi ouvida não foi
falada não foi escutada mas foi
profundamente sentida e foi sentida uma
dúvida cruel
afinal de contas este silêncio ou não e
aí esta palavra não falada podem
encontrar uma ajuda enorme para ser
expressa que é o jeito de dizer o jeito
de falar
a maneira de não expressar ou expressar
então se alguém diz você ainda me ama e
eu simplesmente baixo a cabeça não óleo
para os seus olhos não digo coisa alguma
o talvez saia
aí eu tenho muitas respostas para uma
palavra que não foi pronunciada para uma
palavra que não foi dita mas isto ainda
não é o pior
eu acho que o pior de tudo é a maneira
como nós usamos a palavra porque ela tem
força por si como uma pedra tem força
eu posso ter uma bola de canhão alguém
já viu uma bola de canhão acho que não é
difícil mas se imagina o que é uma bola
de canhão sabe aquelas desenho animado
aquela bola parece de boliche imagine
que aquela bola
ela pode fazer um estrago danado
eu por exemplo poderia jogá la aqui no
colo do vice-presidente já seria o
estrago razoável mas eu também podia
usar o estilingue gigante para
arremessá-la e aí certamente faria um
estrago muito maior nele é e talvez em
quem tivesse ali na fileira atrás dele
mas eu também posso usar um canhão mesmo
que possa tirar esta mesma bala daqui
pra lá e aí certamente o derrubaria
metade deste auditório talvez chegando
lá ao primeiro andar vai se saber porquê
embora a bala seja a mesma o meio que
utilizo para lançá-la fará toda a
diferença
então neste sentido quando nós
utilizamos certos mecanismos para
levarmos a palavra o outro isto fará
toda a diferença
vocês já pararam para pensar que as
palavras bondosa as amorosas gostosas
lindas extraordinárias são sempre ditas
meio que sussurrados é estranho ninguém
sai por aí dizem eu te amo é tentar pé
do ouvido e etc mas já parou pra pensar
porque as palavras odiosa são ditas aos
gritos e quando eu vou dizer eu te odeio
e nunca deu e adiyia mas eu gritei berro
eu te odeio não suporto porque você está
assim imagine que se as palavras têm
força por si e eu o utilizo no meio
deste link uma força tão grande para
arremessar uma palavra que não presta o
quanto esta palavra adquire força para
poder modificar a vida daquela pessoa
que vai receber esta palavra
uma das experiências mais bonitas que eu
tive na vida foi voltando da paróquia
passando no bairro de santo antônio
encontrei uma barulheira danada um carro
àquela hora da noite disse mas o que é
isso e então fui lá ver
sabe o que era era um homem que a vida
toda bebeu maltratou a sua esposa saiu
de casa acabou com seu casamento e
depois de dois anos resolveu voltar e
ele resolveu voltar em grande estilo
ele contratou um carro de som contratou
orquestra levou na frente da casa da
mulher e ele dizia assim a vida inteira
eu tirei o som a vida inteira eu tenho
porto ney a vida inteira eu em português
os nossos vizinhos gritando berrando e
brigando hoje eu quero importunar a você
e aos nossos vizinhos ea todos cantando
porque eu ainda te amo espero que você e
de miami
eu quero voltar achei aquilo
extraordinário porque pela primeira vez
ele tenha usado a palavra não para
gritar berrar as coisas que não presta
mas ele tenha usado a palavra para
gritar berrar as coisas que são mais
sagradas pra ele
afinal de contas ele ainda ama a esposa
dele
que coisa extraordinária achei lindo
achei bonito aquilo mas olha tome
cuidado porque as palavras verdadeiras
ou falsas
elas têm de fato poder e força e ainda
mais agora quando nós temos milhares de
maneiras levá las aos outros porque
antes estas formas de levarmos as
palavras eram restritas você escreveria
e enviava você falava pessoalmente ou
com a evolução você telefonava mas tudo
era tão cara tão caro tão difícil
hoje a palavra pode ser enviada
instantaneamente e ela pode ser enviada
não só a palavra escrita mas a palavra
falada ea palavra vista em questão de
segundos
eu tenho meios e condições de enviar a
qualquer parte do mundo não importa onde
você esteja a palavra que eu quero que
você receba seja boa ou ruim
a grande questão é tendo poder assim
como tenha palavra o que realmente eu
tenho feito das palavras que o uso se
nós queremos construir um mundo melhor
precisamos aprender a escolher as
palavras que vamos usar para construir
esse então talvez se nós parássemos hoje
para pensarmos nas palavras que
escrevemos que falamos e que ouvimos só
no dia de hoje
aí já daria pra gente ter uma idéia de
mais ou menos do tipo de palavras que
nós estamos utilizando o estamos ouvindo
este diz
estes dias com os meus alunos em sala de
aula pedi para eles por favor peguem os
seus celulares em treinos e what's up
selecione as cinco últimas pessoas com
quem você conversou e faça uma análise
muito rápida do conteúdo que vocês
trocaram na última hora ou as dez
últimas mensagens de vocês fizeram foi
surpreendente como se vocês premência
aquele conteúdo ali não tinha quase nada
perguntei para os meus alunos vocês
estão satisfeitos com o que estão lendo
você está satisfeito com o que escreveu
está satisfeito como que recebeu não
mas por que escreveu o que te levou a
escrever estas coisas todas que você
escreveu aí
nestes tempos de redes sociais onde
facilmente a gente joga palavras no ar e
atinge pessoas de todos os tipos de
todos os modos conhecidos e
desconhecidos
nestes tempos em que a palavra se
transformou numa palavra que se
estilhaça atingindo inúmeras pessoas
inclusive para
aquelas que não foram enviadas como
chumbo que se espalha no um tiro e
atinge não somente o meu alvo mas também
as pessoas que estão em sua volta
de fato a gente precisa repensar com
vamos utilizar as nossas palavras e
claro nada melhor do que a gente avaliar
a palavra falada a palavra sentida a
palavra consentida a palavra pensada
a gente não pode sair por aí jogando
palavras sem sentido sem correção sem
direção
as palavras ao vento talvez não faça o
efeito que nós gostaríamos que fizesse
talvez façam outros efeitos e talvez não
seja isso que a gente deseja
então deixo aqui para todos nós esta
mensagem
cada um de nós pense e repense no uso da
palavra porque você querendo ou não ela
vai fazer o efeito concreto direto e
reto seja positivo ou negativo
vai depender de como sair de dentro de
você
como chega no outro e meio eu utilizei
que você saiba sempre utilizar duas
palavras que você possa construir o
mundo à sua família seus amigos as suas
amizades os seus relacionamentos que as
suas palavras sejam doces e amargas
sejam sempre para construir porque nem
sempre é possível falar palavras doces
às vezes as palavras amargas também são
necessárias porque são remédios mas seja
como for ou que a sua intenção seja
única e exclusiva e exclusiva a intenção
de construir o outro de reconstruir o
outro de animar o outro de fazer com que
o outro se coloca nesse mundo
desejo profundamente desejo de construir
um mundo melhor que as minhas palavras
nesta noite também possam lhe ajudar a
você viver nesta sociedade que cada vez
mais pela palavra pelo pensamento pelo
sentimento operação precisa ser
reflexiva
muito obrigado a todos